اختاروا يا بريله انه الثاني من ابريل
وخلفي يوجد مبنى اداره مدينه باخموت من
الناحيه القانونيه لقد اخذنا باخموت
وسيرفع قاده الوحدات التي استولت على مبنى
الاداره والمنطقه المركزيه باكملها هذه
الاعلام العدو لا يزال متمركزا في الاجزاء
الغربيه من المدينه
كان هذا الحديث ليفدين زعيم قوات فاجنر
الروسيه حديث رد عليه المتحدث باسم
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه الشرقيه
لقد رفعوا العلم على مراحيض رفعوه في مكان
مجهول علقوا قطعه قماش وقالوا انهم
استولوا على المدينه حسنا فلندعهم يعتقدون
انهم استولوا عليها تقول المعلومات ان
اشتداد حده التصريحات بين الطرفين يعكس
اشتداد حراره المعارك بينهما امر لم ينفه
ولا حتى الرئيس الاوكراني
الاجواء مشتعله في باخمه اليوم على وجه
الخصوص بالقرب من بيلوهوريفكا وكريم وجميع
مدننا وبلداتنا وقران الاخرى في دومباس
وفقا لتصريحات الجانبين فان المعارك تدور
على الضفه الغربيه من النهر الذي يشطر
المدينه الى نصفين في محيط مبنى مجلس
باخموت وسط المدينه اذ تتمركز القوات
الروسيه الى الشرق والشمال منه بعد
سيطرتها على المنطقه الصناعيه شمالا في
حين تتمترس القوات الاوكرانيه في الجهه
المقابله غربا ومع تصاعد سخونه المعارك
والتصريحات حول المدينه التي تشهد اطول
معركه في الحرب الاوكرانيه لا شيء مؤكد
فيها حتى اللحظه الا صوت الرصاص والموت
رائد المصطفى العربيه